- We talked about the educational system,
a little bit about law
enforcement, a lot about children,
but children grow up, and
they need a healthcare system
that's gonna support
them in a meaningful way.
So I think our next
presentation will talk about
a project that accomplished
some of those goals.
So I'd like to introduce
the members of the CART team.
Jo Cummins here, is our program director
for the Office of
Developmental Primary Care,
and Pat Mejia is the,
next to her is the program
manager and community liaison
for the Office of
Developmental Primary Care.
Next we have Dr. Zoe Collins,
who is a licensed psychologist in Oakland.
And following that is Dr. Eva Ihle,
and Dr. Ihle is faculty at UCSF,
she completed her general
psychiatry residency,
child and adolescent
psychiatry fellowship,
and post-doc all at UCSF,
and she's currently the director
of the Community Consultation Program
in the division of Child and
Adolescent Psychiatry at UCSF,
and the interim medical director
of the division of Infant,
Child, and Adolescent Psychiatry
at San Francisco General.
The final member in the
panel is Dr. Clarissa Kripke,
many of you know Dr. Kripke,
she is a clinical professor and director
of the Office of
Developmental Primary Care,
and the Department of Family
and Community Medicine at UCSF,
and for over a decade,
has really been devoted
to the project of improving
our healthcare system
in the state of California,
and beyond if she could,
for adults with, and adolescents
with developmental disabilities.
So today I'm gonna talk about
some of the lessons
learned from our CART team.
And some of you may know
what CART stands for,
but in case you don't, and
we have no disclosures,
I'm gonna go through sort of
an overview of the CART model,
and then talk specifically about
what the CART Mobile Services Project team
was all about, and what we tried to do,
as well as sort of what our mission was,
and then we're gonna hear
from members of the team
about the caregiver assessment component,
as well as some of the clinical themes,
and then finally wrapping up with
what some of our lessons
learned from this project were,
as well as some of the challenges.
So the CART Model, many of
you have seen this before,
but really the CART Model
is based upon the notion
and the value that healthcare for people
with developmental disabilities
is interdisciplinary,
is team-based, and always
has patients and caregivers,
and I would add community
at the core of this model.
And you can see that the top of the model
is really enhanced primary
care, and care coordination,
and we know that our
healthcare system right now
remains woefully inadequate
in terms of providing care
for people with
developmental disabilities.
And a major mission of this project
was to help build capacity
within the healthcare workforce
in California to provide
for a better quality care.
The vision here is really to ensure
that all people with
developmental disabilities
have access to healthcare services
that are going to maximize
not just their healthcare,
but their wellness and their function.
The CART services,
CART is Clinical Advocacy
Research Training
and Technical Assistance.
I will say that the R is a
small R because there's been,
the focus has been much more
on providing clinical services,
advocacy, and training.
The yearly health assessment component
is actually more of the proactive
and preventive part of the CART Model,
which really advocates
to have a comprehensive
yearly assessment for individuals
with developmental disabilities,
and then health advocacy
is something that I think the CART Model
does incredibly well,
and is demonstrated with some
of the amazing resources
that you see on the website.
So what did our services
team do, and who are we?
We are a multidisciplinary team
that provides healthcare consultations,
including, includes
experts in primary care,
which is Dr. Kripke and myself,
psychiatry, which is Dr. Ihle,
psychology, which is Dr. Collins,
and then our incredible team of
community liaison, parent,
and advocates with Pat and Joe.
And, oh I see, I can see it over here.
So our focus is actually
on adolescents and adults
with developmental disabilities,
but not only clients,
but also the clinicians, family members,
and also the caregivers,
and people who support them
in the community, which
are really vital part
of what we did when we went
out to provide service.
This program really came about,
it started I think, the beginning
started way back in 2006
with some of the Grassroots
Initiative from the CART model,
and I think the mobile consult team
is actually an actualization
of some of that
really hard work that's
happened over the past decade.
For the first time, this
is really a collaboration
among regional centers,
so not just one regional center,
but there were six regional centers
who collaborated on this project.
And I'll show you in a minute what,
where some of our swath of services
geographically served.
So what we did, was we provided both,
and this was a project that
occurred over three years
and ended in June in 2018,
yes, okay.
We did phone and email consultations
that came from a variety of sources,
from clinicians, from parents,
from caregivers, clients, and clients.
We did a comprehensive
assessment and consultation,
which I'll talk about in a minute.
We did a lot of training, and
I'll tell you more about that,
as well as developing policy and advocacy
statements and materials,
and some of which you
can see in the booth out,
right outside this door here,
which has lots of the
materials from the website.
As well as, this program
actually helped us support
this conference for several years as well.
So, this is a map of where we served,
and basically you can
see we moved all the way
from Del Norte County in
the north, down to Monterey.
It was amazing to go to these
different geographic regions
and see the differences in the geography,
in the services, in the regional centers,
and also to see where people
lived in these communities,
and the kinds of supports that they had.
I think we learned a lot,
and what is different about
this kind of a project
where you go into the community,
and you go into people's
homes or programs,
is that you are their guest,
and that actually you learn so much more
by seeing people in the
context of the environment
with which they work and they live.
And I think it added a
richness to our ability
to make suggestions and recommendations
on how to improve quality of care.
I do have to also say, and
give a little shout-out
to the TACT team, because
I've been a member
of the Redwood Coast
Regional Center TACT team,
and I know there's a
number of TACT team folks
here in the audience,
and some of the elements
of our comprehensive consult
were really built upon
some of the components
that we've used for years
in the TACT team, so good job TACT team.
So the comprehensive consults by topic,
so this is the pie chart that talks about
what kind of problems we addressed
with a comprehensive consult,
and the largest number
was a decline in functions,
which is a very non-specific reason,
and really required a deep dive
into sort of all aspects
of the person's wellbeing, both medical,
psychiatric, environmental, etcetera.
That was followed by behavioral
issues as one of the,
as the reason for the consultation.
Sometimes followed by a medical
review of recurring symptoms
that did not seem to be resolving
with traditional treatment,
or with lots of different
types of treatment modalities.
Placement issues followed that,
by diagnosis meaning, don't
know what the heck is going on,
and then a small percentage,
a review of the person's
recent hospitalization.
So what is the comprehensive consult?
The comprehensive consult
is one that the client
is referred by a regional center,
usually a service coordinator,
or other member of the regional center.
And typically the person
has really complex medical,
behavioral, psychiatric issues,
that puts them at risk
for losing their placement
in the community, or
needing to go to perhaps,
a higher level of care.
Our consult, the purpose of the consult
was to really try to do
a really comprehensive look
at all aspects of that
person's functioning,
and medical, psychiatric,
environmental issues,
and to come up with
recommendations and suggestions
that would hopefully help the person
lead a better quality of life.
Typically, we would
start with an extensive
medical record review, which
this is not a crisis team,
so we had to plan this,
generally, a couple months in advance.
We would take any number
of the whole team,
or depending on what the needs
and the issues identified,
where we might take just a smaller number
of the team members,
but I have to say, every
time we went out there
without Dr. Ihle or Dr. Collins,
we would think, God I wish they were here.
Because there was always
issues with mental health,
or with general happiness,
and behavioral issues,
and so we really found that
that was just really a key component.
You want me to hurry up?
Is that, okay?
- We're running out of time.
- Okay, all right.
Okay, I'm gonna hurry up then.
So, what else do I want to say about that,
nothing, okay.
So I'm just gonna talk a
little bit about training,
and then I'm gonna pass it on, okay.
I thought I was hurrying.
So training, so we did lots of trainings,
the trainings actually
I think were incredibly,
incredibly important in terms of
helping the local
community, the caregivers,
the ILS staff, and the clients
actually understand what
resources were available to them.
We did trainings for, in
hospitals and emergency rooms,
in ILS groups,
with families and caregivers,
and the topics are listed here.
I have to say the response
was really wonderful
to the trainings and I
think most of that material
that we've used is
actually on our website.
So I think I'm gonna pass it along now,
'cause I'm getting the,
we've gotta hurry up mode.
And I'm gonna pass this on to Dr. Collins,
who's gonna go next.
Dr. Kripke's gonna go next?
Well actually I thought it was,
- Yeah, yeah.
- You're just gonna
cut to the end?
- Cut to the end.
- Well before you cut to the end though,
could you just talk a little bit about
the caregiver assessment?
No, okay.
- But you're welcome to stop at our table,
and I'll be happy to fill you in.
Really, okay,
okay.
- [Dr. Kripke] Okay, great.
We have a lot to say about,
this is a fabulous team,
and we got started a little late,
and we don't wanna keep you from lunch,
so we are going to truncate
what we had to say,
but some of the unique
features of the program
include doing caregiver consults,
which were separate from
the client consults that we did.
We did a lot of work in trauma,
trauma and trauma
histories were at the basis
of almost every consult that we had,
and you speak so articulately on this,
I can't stand it, you have to say it.
(group laughing)
- [Dr. Collins] I mean
heard a lot this morning
about trauma, and some of
the things that happened
with a lot of the children.
One of the things that came across
in a lot of evaluations that we did,
is that when people got
caught up in the day-to-day
caregiving for individuals with
developmental disabilities.
What lapsed, or what got forgotten,
or some of the experiences they had.
And so when we were presented
with situations like,
Johnny will not leave the house,
or Susan will not eat green food,
or you know,
a person is withdrawn and
wouldn't leave their room,
what had gotten forgotten,
was that their caregiver
suddenly passed away.
Every time someone left the house,
they were being put in restraints,
or they were being moved
to a different facility.
Every time strangers came to the home,
that meant that something
bad was going to happen.
Every time they interacted with people,
the reciprocal interaction was negative.
And so those things were forgotten,
but all they wanted to happen
was for us to fix Johnny
leaving the house,
Susan coming out of her room,
or someone else eating green things.
And so often times, our
job was to bring back
into perspective the
entire experience that
that person brought with them,
so that we can build the
empathy and compassion
in the care again, so that
in the day-to-day caregiving,
we didn't forget those things.
So instead of put your hands down,
stop blocking us from leaving the door,
it's gonna be okay, we're not
gonna take you somewhere else,
you live here forever, we're
just going to your day program.
Because sometimes those
little changes in tone,
attitude, and approach
made a huge difference
in the day-to-day functioning
of the individual that
we were there to serve.
- [Dr. Kripke] And the
richness of these comprehensive
consults were really to dig
deep into their past history,
not just what the people in
their present lives know,
but to dig as deeply
as we could to find out
what people's stories were,
and once you understood that context,
it really made a huge
difference in their care.
We focused, the team experimented
with a variety of ways
to create efficiencies,
with the hope that we
could reduce the amount
of highly skilled labor, travel,
or resources that we needed
to do solid assessments,
and to create comprehensive
and practical sets of recommendations.
But what we found was that there's really,
there are no shortcuts, that
this is labor-intensive,
that it takes expertise,
that it takes the whole team,
and that it takes going
to their environment,
we can't do this by telemedicine.
And we actually serve some people
that the TACT team had served,
and who provided services to,
but when we went out there,
we had a really different perspective,
and a different set of recommendations
than when it was done completely remotely.
So taking the time also, to
write our comprehensive reports
was very labor-intensive,
but synthesizing that data
from multiple disciplines
and multiple sources
was a critical services to
get teams on the same page,
and to create a common understanding
of what the issues were
so that people could work
together effectively.
We often thought that we
had a really good idea
of what was going on with the client
based on talking to
their case coordinators,
and doing that comprehensive
review of records,
which was often a quite thick stack.
But even the reason for
the consult was different
when we actually got out there,
even the chief complaint wasn't the same.
And if we don't understand
the nature of the problem,
like you were alluding to Zoe,
then we can end up spending
an awful lot of resources,
getting very frustrated,
and not providing an
effective service for that,
so doing that deep dive,
and finding out what the real issue was,
often the solutions
weren't that complicated.
Sometimes they were, they
usually were not more expensive
than what was already being
spent on these clients
who were the people who were in
the most difficult situations,
and so we were already spending
an enormous amount of resources,
a lot of people were
involved in their care,
but ineffective services
aren't cost-effective ever.
For example, we were told that somebody
was very highly aggressive,
but what we found was
that they had a neurological tick,
and if you happen to get in the
way, it wasn't a good thing.
And or, we were told that they were sick
and failing to thrive,
and they were getting very
expensive medical workups,
and when we got out there,
we found that there was
no food in their cupboard.
It takes experience, and
expertise to sort out
clients who have complex
combinations of developmental,
medical, behavioral, psychiatric,
and environmental issues,
and to tell a coherent story
about where they've been
about what needs to be done
to get them where they need to be,
and there really isn't
a shortcut for that.
And so we were only, in
order to expand the impact
of our work beyond the
individuals that we worked with,
we did a lot of follow-up
work that impacted
the entire community, and
helped to build the workforce,
which was really the goal.
For example, a recurring theme
was that attitudes were a major barrier
to healthcare access, and we
went to the local hospitals,
and we talked to the
local service providers,
and we empowered the
local service providers
to provide information, and
we met with Grand Rounds,
we met with the local
providers to really explain
who people with developmental
disabilities are,
what their potential is, and
why they should receive care
and services like anybody else.
We did quite a bit of training,
especially around communication,
around goals of care conversations,
and on successful community living,
and that really changed the relationship
between these healthcare facilities,
and healthcare provider groups,
and the regional centers,
and their clients.
We also invited local community clinicians
to come to our comprehensive consults,
and watch us work with the
patients that they were serving,
and that they had been struggling through,
trying to diagnose, and trying to serve,
and went to them,
and talked to them about
their challenging situations.
Medical education doesn't, I mean,
this is a fabulous conference,
and medical articles are great,
but medical education
is apprenticeship style,
we have to show people how to do,
we can't just talk about it,
we have to show it in
practice with their patients,
in the context that
they're actually practicing
for people to get better at it.
And by going out to these communities,
and doing these consults,
we were able to do that
kind of very hands-on training,
and to model what we teach in practice.
And in terms of systems issues, there is,
a lot of focus is on the
services that are being provided
in higher level group homes,
and medically oriented,
and behaviorally oriented group homes,
but most of our clients
were not in those homes,
and most people with
developmental disabilities
don't live in those homes.
So if you focus solely on the people
who are living in those homes,
we're really gonna miss the boat on
improving healthcare for the population,
which includes 300,000 people,
only a handful of which live
in these higher level group homes.
Family, direct support professionals,
service providers, they're
front-line healthcare workers.
They recognize illness,
they provide the support
when people are accessing medical care,
they implement the healthcare plans,
and those people need training,
support, and oversight.
And when we went into these communities,
we were able to provide them
with some of that training,
and support, and encouragement,
and recognition for the
important role that they have,
and the important job that they're doing
that impacts healthcare,
it's not just about what doctors do,
it's not just what clinicians do,
it's not just what nurses do,
it's also those hands-on support people,
and families that are
making a big difference.
And we also notice that, in
terms of system problems,
that we focus so much on these high-level
group homes that have a lot
of medical resources in them,
and while they're fabulous,
and necessary, and important,
a recurrent theme was
that people who don't live
in those homes, don't have
access to skilled nursing,
even when they have skilled nursing needs,
and a lot of people are being
forced into institutions,
into SNFs, into out-of-state placements
because they don't have
access to skilled nursing
when they live in supported living,
when they live in family homes,
when they live in
behaviorally oriented homes.
Another theme was access
to mental health services
that have expertise in
developmental disabilities.
There are some fields where
taking care of a person
with a developmental disability,
isn't that different than
taking care of everybody else,
but primary care, and
mental and behavioral health
are definitely areas where
special expertise is needed,
and there is a lack of
access to mental healthcare
in general, but a tremendous,
tremendous lack of people
who have actual expertise,
and we're just so glad to have
Dr. Ihle on the team, and doing training,
and providing us with that support,
because non of the other team
members were able to make
the kinds of recommendations,
and to make the kinds of
insights that she was able to do,
that's tremendously important,
and we need to reproduce her.
And a final thing is around
inter-agency collaboration.
There's an awful lot of different people,
whether it's regional centers,
local medical centers, and hospitals,
local, the county mental health systems,
and more, and the direct
service providers,
the families, the schools, every,
all of those different systems,
and local service providers too,
the local agencies who
are providing services,
the parent information training centers,
all of these people have a
role in promoting health,
and we need to work together,
and we need to break down the barriers
that we're not just
pointing fingers and saying,
oh, that's your health plan,
oh, that's the regional center,
oh, that's county mental health,
and so that we can not replicate services,
because a lot of times
each of those agencies
has a different care coordinator,
and we're doing a lot of duplicate work
that we could be doing once.
And then we need to break down,
make real decisions
about who's responsible
for what when we have these
complicated situations,
so that we can work as a team,
not just this team, but
also that community team.
Thanks.
- You have two minutes.
- [Dr. Ihle] I feel that
we're so far behind,
but I'll just put in a plug
for psychiatry (laughs).
As the discipline that focuses on
trying to understand whether there are
neurophysiological underpinnings
to changes in behavior,
and the changes in behavior
that we are often asked
to consult on were either
decreases in functionality,
or worsening behavior
in terms of agitation,
or what was called disruptive behavior.
And if we think about these things
as manifestations of what the physiology
of the nervous system is doing,
then I think that will also
provide additional insights
that maybe the care providers
hadn't been considering,
or hadn't been included in the care plans.
- Final words?
I just want to give a shout-out
to our caregiving team here,
care provider support
assessment, Pat and Joe,
did a great job, and I
think that is something
that often times, not included,
and actually is a really important part
in terms of someone's health.
We know the caregiving forces is aging,
and we know that we need
more good caregivers,
and they need support
to do the kind of job
that they have to do.